tom holland says he and zendaya love
each other very much i mean dude i'm
just as excited as the fans but didn't
want to share their relationship with
the world the 25 year old actor covers
gq's men of the year issue and reveals
how his spider-man no way home co-star
felt when pics of them kissing in a car
were leaked in july quote one of the
downsides of our fame is that privacy
isn't really in our control anymore and
a moment that you think is between two
people that love each other very much is
now a moment that is shared with the
entire world look the internet can be a
cynical place and it was overall joy it
seemed when those pictures came out well
thank you
of course romance rumors between the
pair have been swirling ever since the
first spider-man press tour in 2017.
have you found that it's hard to date in
hollywood that's such a young age of
course it is i mean it's hard today at
any age in fact at the time zendaya
dished on all that chatter to e.t it
happens all the time and of course you
know we we expected it i mean it's um
it comes with the territory it comes
with the job so it's all good
but in 2021 those kissing picks only
reignited the rumors i am sweating while
neither tom nor zendaya officially
confirms their love they did spend the
fourth of july together and have praised
each other in interviews and on social
media today i got to give you a belated
happy birthday very sweet post from tom
what was it like to see the post and i
noticed you commented calling now
no it's i mean i i am yeah i was it was
sweet i guess i don't know now tom says
that he's always tried to keep his
private life private adding that they
both felt like they were quote robbed of
their privacy when those kissing snaps
surfaced and the actor says it's not
that they weren't ready to talk about
their rumored romance but rather they
didn't want to quote it's not a
conversation that i can have without her
this isn't my story it's our story and
we'll talk about what it is when we're
ready to talk about it together as for
zendaya she tells the mag that the whole
situation was quote strange and weird
and confusing and invasive quote the
equal sentiment we both share is that
when you really love and care about
somebody some moments or things you wish
were your own i mean it's just hard to
say in general you know sometimes it's
hard to you know find people that you
really click with or really understand
you and and add on top of the fact that
my lifestyle is very different so i mean
it's just tough but i'm chilling but
zendaya didn't hold back when it came to
praising tom for his work telling gq
quote anytime i've ever watched him work
he does it 150 percent it's incredible
to watch i just feel very lucky of
course tom has played spider-man in five
movies since landing the role in 2015.
and says zendaya a former disney channel
star helped him navigate young fame
quote the ages between 15 and 21 are
when you figure out who you're going to
be when everyone's telling you that
you're the best thing in the world you
can grow up and believe that having her
in my life was so instrumental to my
sanity you ready yeah you're gonna love
this spiderman no way home which is due
out december 17th is the last flick in
tom's spider-man contract and he says he
plans to take a long-awaited break
following its release so mj's gonna
forget about everything we've ever been
through quote it's very strange the last
six years of my life i always had a job
to go to it's kind of terrifying but
it's also really exciting